DAVID HEARNDEN: This morning
I'll be talking to you about
concurrent data and some
operational transform
alternatives.
And Christian Ohler will also
be joining me a little later
hopefully when he gets here.
So concurrent data--
what does that mean?
I'm going to talk about what the
problem is that concurrent
data needs to solve.
And this talk's going to talk
about two strategies for
providing concurrent data.
One is what we call
embedding--
so embedding concurrent data
on Wave's operational
transformations.
And Christian's going to talk
about some more general
approaches, or using a more
general approach to OT.
So the problem that comes up
when you try and build
applications on Wave
is that wavey
applications need wavey data.
So what that means is when you
try and build a behavior on
top of the Wave platform,
you need to have a data
representation for your model
that is compatible with the
wave platform, which means the
data model is distributed,
it's mutable, and it changes
both from local and remote
operations.
So in Google Wave we have a
number of these application
models, one of which is the
conversation model.
Another is the supplement
model, which
represents your user data.
There are other models like
the attachment model that
represents attachments and their
upload status, gadgets,
participants suggestions,
spelling suggestions--
all these things have their
own data models.
Now normally when you build a
data model, you build it up
out of canonical, mathematical,
pure data
structures that have
tried and tested--
things like sets, maps,
lists, tuples, values.
Now all these kinds of
abstractions have a natural
operational transformation under
concurrent mutations.
For example, if I have a
distributed counter and my
application increments it, and
remotely gets incremented, its
natural at the convergence
state of those two
operations--
once they go over the wire
and get transformed--
the natural resolution is to
increment the counter twice.
So all these kinds of basic
structures have natural
intuitive ways that concurrent
mutations should resolve.
However, on the Wave platform,
there is really just one type
that you get to use, and
that's the type of an
annotated XML document.
So if you need to build up your
application model with
the data structures that you
want, then how do you do it
when there's just one structure
that you can use?
So that's the problem.
How do you build wavey data?
So what I'm going to be talking
about is a strategy to
use this one super type as a
type for all purposes and
making it look like simpler
types by embedding simpler
types into the XML.
So we call this an embedding.
And in order to do an embedding,
you need to address
many different concerns.
You need to be able to encode
the state, encode mutations.
The concurrent resolution
of the transform
needs to be well formed.
You need to be able to normalize
the state, garbage
collection-- all these
different concerns.
All I want to point out is that
it's not as trivial as it
might seem.
But fortunately in the Wave
library's repository, there's
a bunch of embeddings that
we've already done.
So if you're building an
application model to sit on
top of a wavelet, then we
already have done a lot of the
work, ironed out the corner
cases, found all the gotchas,
for a bunch of basic structures,
like basic values,
booleans, maps, lists, sets.
So I'm going to talk about
what it means to embed a
structure in Wave.
And I'm going to give
an example.
So the basic idea is
that you need to
think about two mappings.
One mapping is to interpret
the region of a document.
And by document, I mean
data document.
So in your application you can
choose to use whatever
documents you want
in a wavelet.
Not all of them are textual
documents that are part of a
conversation.
You can have arbitrary documents
that aren't seen.
They're just there
to hold data.
So you need to have a way to
interpret a region of this XML
onto an abstract state, like
interpret it as a list, or
interpret it as a value,
interpret it as a map.
And the second thing you need
to do is given an abstract
mutation like adding a value
to a set or decrementing a
counter, given a mutation on
your abstract data type, a way
to embed that mutation as an
XML document mutation.
So these two mappings, the
interpretation and the
embedding, have a number
of constraints that
they have to satisfy.
They need to commute, compose,
and transform.
So just this first property
of needing to commute--
this just says that if you
interpret then mutate, you get
the same result as if you
mutate, then interpret.
Again there's not enough
time to delve
too deeply into detail.
The main point is that it does
require some thought to do it.
It's not completely trivial.
There's plenty of gotchas.
And we've done a lot
of the work for
basic structures already.
So these are some of the things
that you need to think
about if you're writing
and embedding.
The main thing you need to know
is the fine details of
how the XML document operations
compose and
transform and commute.
And you also need to know
given your embedding of
mutations, what is the entire
space of possible document
states that could be reached
under all forms of composition
and transformation.
You need to think about making
sure that the empty state is a
meaningful state--
all these different concerns.
So I'm just going to run through
probably the most
trivial example of
an embedding.
And this is a monotonic map.
So the use case that drove
needing to use this monotonic
map was in the supplement
model, which tracks your
personal user data on
a wave, we track
your reading activity.
So when you read a blip, we
record that you've read it.
And the way we record that
you've read it is to record a
map of the blip ID to the
version of the blip at which
you read it.
So essentially we want a
map-like abstraction where we
put blip ID and version numbers
in, and we can read a
version number out for an ID.
So that's just a regular map.
What makes it monotonic is
that we want the behavior
where if you happen to read a
wave in an old state, then
that doesn't override the fact
that you've read it in the
newer state.
So if you've read a blip at
version 100, and then for
whatever reason you see a stale
or old copy of the wave,
and you read that blip again
at version 20, we want the
state to remain that you've
read it at version 100.
So this means that as you put
things in the map, we only
take the maximum value of
versions that you put in.
So this little XML fragment
here is how we embed a map
into XML of a data document.
So this is just a
fragment within
some part of a document.
We use entry elements.
Here they've got a tag name of
read with two attributes for
an ID and a version.
And under concurrent activity,
you can get multiple entries
with the same ID, multiple
entries with
the same ID and version.
You can get multiple entries of
the same version of course.
So you can get pretty much
any arbitrary state.
And so the way we interpret it
is just to pretty obviously of
all the entries for a given
ID, pick the one with the
maximum value.
And that's the interpretation
as a map.
Another important property is
that any other elements that
happen to be in there, we
just leave them alone.
We don't consider that the map
sort of owns this region.
This means you can embed many
of these structures in the
same place in an XML document.
So the interpretation
is just to pick the
maximum of what's there.
These are the embedding
strategies for
mutating the map.
And again the monotonic map is
one of the simplest cases.
So in this case the mutation to
put a value in the map, the
way we mutate the XML structure
is we just prepend a
new entry into the list, and
then afterwards find all the
other entries that have the same
ID and delete them all.
That's like a garbage
collection step.
And it's important to add the
new entry first before
deleting the other ones.
Because this comes from the
atomicity and where the
transaction boundaries are for
the document operations.
This compound operation of
putting in entries and
deleting other entries can
get arbitrarily framed or
arbitrarily split up.
So you need to understand
what's going on in the
document operations to know that
you need to put the new
entry in first rather than
delete the other ones, so you
don't get invalid intermediate
state.
And the other embeddings are
pretty straightforward.
So just to apply that
to the example--
for this state on the left, if
we interpret that as a map and
we want to do the abstract
mutation to put a new value in
the map of mapping the key aab
to the value 30, then on the
right, we can see the
change that that
makes to the XML structure.
It adds a new entry and deletes
all the other entries
that have the same ID.
And this strategy composes
properly.
It works under transforms.
So if two people update the
map at the same time, the
resulting XML state that comes
from the document operations
and the document transforms,
that resulting XML state gets
interpreted as the correct
map state that we want.
So this is just an example of
how to do it in the code that
Wave libraries gives you.
And it's designed to be
really easy to use.
I hope you can see this
reasonably well.
All I want to point out is
that there's a bunch of
utility classes called document
based monotonic map,
document based value, document
based boolean,
document based list.
All these embedding strategies
are there in the libraries.
In this example, we're creating
a monotonic map in a
region of a document.
And what that gives us
is something that
has a map-like interface.
So below you can see that
we just put values in.
And we can get values out.
And we can treat this thing just
like a map even though
it's all XML under the hood.
All these structures
are also live.
You can add listeners.
And the listeners get
notified when the
abstract state changes.
So there's a bunch of provider
types that are already there.
And that's all I was going
to talk about.
Christian is now going to come
up and talk about how you
might do things differently.
Any questions?
We might take them all
at the end I think.
CHRISTIAN OHLER: Cool.
I need to [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID HEARNDEN: Yep.
CHRISTIAN OHLER: All right.
I'm just going to
give you a few
relatively high level ideas.
Because we don't
have much time.
I'm not going to get into
too much technicalities.
Because I think they would only
be of interest to a small
fraction of you.
And you can grab me later if
you want to discuss this in
more detail.
The basic problem
the I see is--
OK.
So that's not actually
the problem.
Wave has made OT
fairly popular.
I think many more people are now
aware that OT is just very
useful for those kind
of collaboration
for real time stuff.
And this one is a problem,
whereas OT is really
complicated.
There are very few people
actually who've gone through
the code and understood
all of it.
It's many thousands
of lines of code.
There's a risk that this leads
to a perception that OT is
really complicated.
But that's not true.
You can actually write your
own OT code to solve very
similar problems,
as Wave does, in
a weekend or something.
So I'm worried that some people
will look at Wave's OT
code and try to understand it
and think, well, this is
really scary.
I'd better just use this as a
black box and I'm just going
to link it in as is it.
So I want to ask you
not to do that.
Because just because Wave's OT
code was developed by a few
Google engineers doesn't mean
that it's particularly good.
I think it's massively
overcomplicated.
So I recognize that in order
for the Wave ecosystem to
work, we need some sort of
standardization or we can't
have everybody doing
their own OT.
We need some kind of
compatibility in order for
systems to be able to
speak to each other.
But I don't actually think, as
I said, that all of you would
go off and do their own OT.
There's only a few people who
are interested in this.
And I think we should be able
to iterate on this stuff.
We shouldn't be stuck with code
that Google published a
little while ago and now base
all of the future on this.
I think it's very risky to
standardize on this magic
black box that is actually too
complicated for anyone to
understand.
And I don't think we can have at
the core of the ecosystem,
this thing that nobody
can really work with.
Also the businesses that are
putting this Wave OT core at
the heart of their products, I
wonder whether they actually
have engineers who are able to
make changes to the core of
their product.
I would like to talk to them.
I would like to talk to those
engineers that can work on the
Wave OT code.
Because it's very hard.
I would like to meet
those people.
So it could be that it's
already too late
to change it here.
But I hope it's not.
Because Wave is still
rather young.
So the root cause of the
complexity of Wave's OT lies
in two things as I
understand it.
That's inheriting annotations.
I think that the Wave model deep
dark talk explained this
a little bit.
So when you insert a new
character, then it inherits
annotations from its
left neighbor.
And this together with the
composability of operations is
what makes everything
complicated.
And I'm just making this
assertion here without
providing any evidence.
But you're going to believe
me anyway, because
I appear very credible.
I said inheriting annotation
is part of the problem.
But let me point out that this
is only inheriting annotations
at the OT core.
You can still have your editor
as you're typing and set up
your editor to send whatever
annotations it wants for the
newly inserted text.
The question is just does the
core OT conflict resolution
algorithm inherent annotations
automatically for you?
Or does it assume that newly
inserted text shouldn't have
any annotations other than what
was explicitly specified?
So about composition,
composition is the ability to
express arbitrary changes to a
document in a single operation.
So those of you who have looked
at Wave's operations
probably noticed that they
have this shape--
retain 20 characters,
and insert ABC.
Then retain five more and
insert some more text.
So in one operation you can make
arbitrary changes to a
document, in arbitrarily
many places.
And when you first see this idea
you sort of think, that
looks kind of nice.
I hadn't thought of that.
It seems very appealing.
And you think, yeah,
that sounds good.
Let's go with that.
It seems mathematically
very appealing.
It seems like a neat approach.
But the truth is that it makes
everything really complicated.
So if you drop either of these
two properties in inheriting
annotations or composability of
operations, you get a much,
much simpler OT system.
And I think the bigger
simplification would come from
dropping composition.
So operations that are not
composable would look
roughly like this.
You would have operations
to insert or
delete contiguous regions.
So you could submerge edits that
are right next to each
other into one operation.
But you no longer require that
insertions and deletions in
completely different places are
expressed as one operation.
Then you still need annotation
operations.
You can restrict them to a
single key in one contiguous
region also.
That part doesn't really
matter so much.
Update and replace attributes
are also not really part of
the problem.
You can keep them the
way they are.
And the details of what this
looks like depends on whether
you want invertible
operations or not.
So do we need composition
actually?
So the Wave code uses
composition
in quite a few places.
And we need some sort
of replacement.
So these operations would no
longer be closed under
composition or transform,
right?
But if you instead look at lists
of operations, as your
primitive, then you still have
a space that is closed under
composition.
Because you can just append
lists of operations as your
composed function.
And the transform property
is obvious.
So the problem with just
appending in order to compose
is that you never reduce the
size of the operation.
You don't really win anything.
So we would have to introduce
a compaction function that
tries to merge a list of
operations into a small number
of operations by dropping
operations that cancel each
other out or that merges
insertions or deletions that
are contiguous.
So it would probably have to
sort the list first by index,
taking care that the indices
actually shift whenever you
change the order of
two operations.
And so all the code that
currently invokes composition
and assumes that the output is
just a single operation would
have to be changed to deal with
the fact that you can now
have a whole list of operations
coming out of the
composition function.
But I think that's
a minor change.
So I think one other detail is
that you would probably also
need to change transform to
return a list of operations in
order for these simple
operations to work.
You will notice this
if you actually
start writing the code.
This gives you the same kind of
product of a feature set as
the OT that we have right now.
So it would not be a user
visible change.
And all you have to do
is write the code.
Now the code will
be very simple.
But in order to ensure the
correctness of our OT code,
we've used one particular
technique.
And that is randomized
testing.
I have the impression that this
is already fairly well
understood by the people
who care about the
code at this level.
So from talking to a few of
you, I have the impression
that you have already
seen the code.
And if you haven't,
just talk to me.
In addition to defining these
compose and transform
functions, you also define
a function that takes the
document state and just
generates a random operation,
just a random change to that
document state that is valid
from the space of all valid
operations that could be
applied to the state.
And then you just invoke
that function twice.
And then you can sort of build
these transform diagrams.
You take two random operations,
transform them
against each other, and look
whether the outcome
converges or not.
That's one of the fundamental
properties that you want your
OT code to satisfy.
You may also be able to use
a model checker or theorem
improver on this simplified
version of OT.
Perhaps it's simple enough.
I haven't thought
about it much.
And again the random operation
generator that we have looks
really complicated.
But that is only because the
operations are composable, and
because annotations inherit.
So don't look at the code in too
much detail and be scared
at the complexity.
Because if you do something
simpler then the complexity
will go away.
So this is the rich text
OT that Wave provides.
This is how you could
simplify it.
But rich text isn't
everything.
As David has just discussed, we
actually want to represent
data as well.
And using Wave's OT as a
foundation for abstract data
types, it is possible, as he has
discussed, and there are
some clever ideas in the
approaches that we are taking.
But that doesn't mean
it's a good idea.
Using Wave's OT as a foundation
for abstract data
types actually makes your life
harder and not easier--
how do we use something really
complicated to do something
really simple?
And it's an interesting
intellectual challenge.
And we sort of tried to go
with this XML data type.
Because we thought it's probably
expressive enough for
our purposes, and it is.
But the code that you need in
order to express what you want
is quite a lot.
And as some of you has already
discovered, writing OT code
for lists, and maps, and tuples,
and so on, for a few
of these primitive well-known
types that programmers use all
the time is actually
really simple.
And these will be a much
better foundation for
embedding higher level
data structures
that you want to express.
And so one idea that has been
discussed a lot is using JSON
instead of XML--
Wave was based on XML.
But JSON is also a standardized
representation for data.
But it expresses the types
of things better.
It's just these tags and
attributes and text, whereas
JSON is erase and maps and
integers, and so on.
So it's actually closer to the
way we program than XML is.
One final thing that Wave
got quite wrong is the
representation of cursors.
Well we didn't quite
get it wrong.
We represent them as annotations
in the document.
And all annotation changes are
persisted as part of the
document history.
And this turns out to have quite
a high storage cost.
Even though persisting cursor
movements is not something
that we ever intended to
do, we just use the
model in this way.
And it worked, which is
why we stuck with it.
But we've been fairly
unhappy about
this on various occasions.
And if you look at what you
really need to store for
cursors, each session
has its own cursor.
There is no real concurrent
modification of this cursor by
multiple parties.
It's just one client setting
its cursor position.
So it's a much simpler
problem than OT.
However the cursor position
needs to be adjusted whenever
some text gets inserted
somewhere.
So if you look at your document,
Hello World, with my
cursor, in fact, at position 14,
if you just think of the
cursors as a separate map that
is outside the document, then
you need to adjust the cursor
positions whenever text gets
inserted or deleted before the
cursor to keep the index in
the same context.
And this is also
not very hard.
And you should talk to Soren
if you want to know more
detail about this--
or to me of course.
And then I'll point
you to Soren.
Similar ideas apply to read on
read state, as David Hearnden
just discussed.
We saw the read on read state
in XML with these monotonic
maps and so on.
But also the OT conflict
resolution for the read
version is so simple.
You just take the maximum.
You don't really need history
for this either.
You don't need to store history
for what the user just
read, when you're never going
to use [INAUDIBLE]
on this information anyway.
So to summarize, Wave's OT
is way over complicated.
And having everybody rely on
this central piece without
anybody understanding
it is fairly risky.
I think we should be
able to fix this.
Maybe we are not.
Randomized testing actually
makes it relatively easy.
You still need to take care to
actually write your random
generator properly if your
random generator is bad.
And then again it's not
that hard to find
bugs in your OT code.
Wave's XML works to represent
data is much less nice than
what we could have instead.
And OT is not the only
synchronization
mechanism in the world.
And it has the disadvantage
of requiring
history to be stored.
And there are much simpler
mechanisms that you can use
instead for certain
types of data.
OK.
So that is it.
David and I will answer
questions that you may have.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
immediate transmission of the
live editing behavior, does
that, again, complicate the
[INAUDIBLE]
would that help?
Because obviously you've
got larger messages.
You've got more compaction
in a sense.
CHRISTIAN OHLER: I think you can
keep the same liveness if
you want and still have
a simple OT algorithm.
More questions?
There were quite a few more.
AUDIENCE: I know the Docs team
uses the vertical OT.
Do they use a simpler version
than what Wave's using?
CHRISTIAN OHLER: They use a
version that is both simpler
and more complicated.
So they have a less principled
approach to this.
They didn't do any randomized
testing.
And their OT code doesn't
actually converge.
It doesn't matter if you use the
product most of the time.
It's on the divergence that you
were mentioning yesterday.
Docs actually has
that problem.
So it doesn't really matter
much in practice.
So for text editing, it doesn't
really matter that
much in practice if you have
divergences briefly.
Because as soon as
someone reloads
something, it goes away.
But if you want to synchronize
data, I think it's more
problematic.
Because humans don't have a very
strict interpretation of
what they see anyway.
But computers do.
And their OT is also
fairly messy.
But there are other problems
that they don't have.
For example they didn't worry
about composability at all,
which simplifies their approach
a little bit.
More questions?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Were there, I guess,
business cases that you guys
did a more complicated version
like inherited annotations
where the user clicks
Bold [INAUDIBLE]
bolded because of inherits.
Is that how you guys do that?
Or just [INAUDIBLE]
thing to realize later
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: So this is exactly the
kind of situation that you
have to think about when you
discuss whether you want
inheriting annotations
are not--
these use cases.
So if you don't have inheriting
annotations, you
need to send a little bit more
data in the case where you
want annotations to inherit.
You first click Bold and then
starts typing something--
so the first character would
still have to be marked Bold
explicitly by the editor.
But the subsequent characters
would inherit the boldness
from their left neighbor.
You can save a little bit of
data transmission if you have
inheriting annotations
in this situation.
But there are many annotations
that you don't really want to
inherit, for example the
spelling correction
annotations.
I think it's really annoying
that sometimes something is
underlined.
And if you have a somewhat
flaky connection, the
annotation will extend to
everything else that you type
until it hits the server and
comes back, and the server
removes the annotation
for you.
So there are some annotations
for which you want
inheritance, and some
annotations for which you
don't want inheritance.
And maybe it would be best from
a perspective of catering
to the use cases to have both
options on a per annotation
basis or something.
You could specify whether
they inherit or not.
But adding this kind of logic
in the OT layer, again, it
complicates it a little bit.
And I don't know how much.
I haven't thought about what it
would take to offer both of
these options.
AUDIENCE: Can you associate a
sort of annotation type with a
cursor and then have multiple
cursors, so if you're hovering
over the spell check, can you
have a cursor for the spell
check that's associated with
that, maybe to the right, that
you've got to insert the
cursor or whatever.
And then you just pass the
cursor state with [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTIAN OHLER: Yeah, that's
something to think about.
I can't answer whether that's a
good idea or not off the top
of my head.
AUDIENCE: Forgive me if you've
covered this already.
But if you get rid of
composability and send them
lists of operations--
because the client, while you're
offering up operations
[INAUDIBLE], and they're not
being composed together but
they're being concatenated
and compacted--
is the service side OT
complexity center the same for
it to apply that list of
operations as it would be for
[INAUDIBLE]?
CHRISTIAN OHLER: The service
side OT complexity is not the
same if you use an [? NAU ?]
transform implementation.
But you can implement an
efficient transform that
builds an internal
representation that splits the
document into different stripes
that are affected by
the different operations.
And you can implement transform
efficiently still.
But that is code that we don't
currently have for our current
operations.
So our current operations also
suffer from a similar problem.
There is still the potential of
service side explosion of
complexity with the OT that
we have right now.
And the composability
alleviates
that to some degree.
And if you don't have the
composability anymore, then
you need to worry
about it again.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Well I was actually
going to ask now--
the idea of focality of a
[? Nexus ?] or token document
chunks chunks occurring
on those operations.
I'll just talk to
you later on.
CHRISTIAN OHLER: That's
a good idea, I think.
A question on this side?
I wasn't really--
any more questions?
Any questions for--
yeah, sorry.
AUDIENCE: If you have this more
[INAUDIBLE] of operations
in place of these big chunk
operations we have at the
moment, do you think that we
should strive for some
[INAUDIBLE]
maintain so much variance so
that there's [INAUDIBLE]?
CHRISTIAN OHLER: Yeah.
I think that the output of
compaction will probably
naturally have some good
properties like that, that the
list of operations essentially
operates on the document from
left to right, or with some
additional constraints like
first, do all insertions and
subtle annotations then do all
divisions or something
like that?
And maybe it's worthwhile to
have a special type for
compacted lists of operations
so that your code can
recognize these and work with
them more efficiently.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Because you [INAUDIBLE]
if you know that they
are smaller.
CHRISTIAN OHLER: Yeah.
But that would basically also
alleviate the complexity
explosion that the previous
question was about.
You would get the same
behavior that
you currently have.
Oh, another question.
AUDIENCE: With the simpler OT
that you're talking about, the
data [INAUDIBLE]
rather than sort
of [INAUDIBLE]?
Would that be a different
scope of Wave protocol?
Or would this have to be
extended protocol?
CHRISTIAN OHLER: Given that
this is what Wave actually
needs, I think it should
be within the
scope of Wave protocol.
Any more questions?
All right.
Thanks very much.
Who's next?
[APPLAUSE]